hi everyone i'm remy danglar
i'm the ceo of stila technologies a
company
based in france and in the us focusing
on
digital pcr technologies applied to life
sciences diagnostics
and today i'll be explaining how
digital pcr can be uh usefully used for
the detection of
kubit-19 and the source code 2 virus
so first of all i'd like to thank the
organizers of the laboratory automation
and informatics events
hosted by lab roots for giving me this
invitation to present digital pcr
and how it can be applied to the
detection and diagnostics of
source code 2 and kobit 19.
this is a great opportunity obviously
this is a very much a
critical aspect of what needs to be done
right now
and the currency today situation of the
epidemic
and so i hope that you can all learn
today about digital pcr its advantages
of
our real-time pcr and again learn how it
can be applied
for this critical application of the
detection and diagnostics of stars cov2
so before i go in the details of the
presentation
i want to explain again what is really
the need
of diagnostics for equipment 19.
so as of today you know there are about
four to five million of cases reported
cases
of kubern19 around the world this is a
worldwide epidemic that is
still growing in exceptional proportions
and we have about 300 000 deaths
accounted for as of today
and that again is a growing and rapidly
growing number so it's it is
obviously an exceptional epidemic that
needs to be treated
with exceptional measures uh and there's
a common understanding right now that a
critical
solution for us to get out of this
epidemic situation is going to be
testing
testing and testing again but when it
comes down to testing you essentially
have
two types of tests you have the
molecular
tests that can be used for diagnostics
and you have the serological test that
really tests for immunity
and for the future of
the control of the epidemic it's really
the diagnostics tests which are going to
matter
because diagnostics tests are able to
diagnose patients
who actively have the disease and
therefore diagnose
patients that present a risk to
contaminate
others and those those individuals
really need to be identified
and we need to take measures to make
sure that they don't infect
others serological tests are obviously
also important
but they only tell us who has been
infected before and who potentially has
immunity
but that will not allow us to prevent
the spread of the disease
further if we only do serological tests
so really the key in my opinion is going
to be
a diagnostics test and as of today
and it's most likely going to remain as
is
in the future um diagnostics tests are
mostly performed using
what is standardly called rt qpcr or
rt-pcr
so pcr with the retros transcript is
step done in real time and this rpt pcr
technology is now very common and used
worldwide to perform millions of tests
every day and again those tests really
are targeted at
patients and individuals who actively
have the disease
and those tests allow us to detect the
virus
from a patient sample
the workflow of rtbcr diagnostics
i believe is now common to to many
people around and probably everyone in
this audience but
it's art stuff with the sample
collection mostly done using
nasal swabs and then the the swab
is put into transport medium as a second
step and there is usually a transport
step to get the sample into the clinical
facility that will perform
the test to perform the test you have
two
main essential test steps sorry you have
the
extraction of the viral rna from the
transport medium
the extraction step and then you have
the analysis by a real-time pcr
so it's a four-step workflow uh
and there are out there solutions that
have integrated some of those steps
combining the extraction with the
analysis but in general this is the
standard workflow
which again uh is performed routinely in
millions of
of tests today but what we know as well
is that there are definitely some
limitations to rtq pcr
testings and there are multiple reports
where
those tests have not been able to
correctly diagnose patients
so one limitation that is known is
there have been frequent accounts of
patients having pneumonia
and having uh so ct abnormalities that
can be clearly seen on ct scans
so you can see such a ct scan on the
right
where you see in the lungs of the
patient's clear evidence
of liquid being present in the lungs
so the patients are obviously ct
positive but the
results of the real-time pcr tests has
come out negative
and that obviously is a
false negative test and is usually
confirmed either
by doing a test by rtpc or later on or
by doing
some sampling directly in the lung of
those patients and that has been
reported in
multiple journals today
similarly there are accounts saying that
real-time qpcr has its sensitivity
of 50 to 70 50 is probably a bit
pessimistic but definitely there is
a lack of sensitivity meaning that there
are about
30 percent of patients who have of
individuals who have the disease
who would not be detected by real-time
pcr
and if you go back to the workflow i
presented before
this could come from different um
origins one the sampling could not have
been performed correctly if you don't do
the same thing correctly if you don't
actually
use the swab correctly you're not going
to collect the virus and you're not
going to be able to detect it
also it's possible that the real-time
pcr analysis is not sensitive in enough
in itself so it's missing some virus
particles some virus genomes in the
sample that is being analyzed
and so in general there's clearly a need
to develop
more sensitive diagnostics workflow in
order to
address this challenge of being able to
grab to to reliably detect and diagnose
patients with cubit 19 and carrying
zarskov2 virus
and so at stila what we decided to
investigate is whether digital pcr
could be a solution to address this
challenge
so before i explain how we have
addressed this question
i'll explain a bit how digital pcr works
in itself
so digital pcr for those of you who are
not familiar with the technology
is essentially the third generation of
pcr technologies
so the first pcr technology is endpoint
pcr
that is done in various indian labs and
was invented back in the 80s
and can be then analyzed using uh
electrophoresis cells so that's on the
left panel
it's a very useful technology but it's
not quantitative it's not very sensitive
at detecting dna or rna nucleic acids
then later on came the second generation
quantitative
dcr or real-time pcr and i guess the
most the best name for it is real-time
pcr
so what real-time pcr brought to the
table
is the ability to detect an increase in
the fluorescence
of of a sample as it is
it undergoes thermocycling and
dna replication and if you detect this
increasing fluorescence it means that
there is presence of the virus that
you're looking for in the sample
so this is a great technology that is
now the workhorse in all labs but it has
some issues that i just mentioned before
and particular sensitivity it's also
not an absolute quantity quantification
tool so meaning you don't really know
how many
material you started out with you just
you can't know whether or not you had
more or less to another reference sample
but it's not absolute
detection and quantification and so
later on came digital pcr and digital
pcr
third generation really addresses uh the
key issues of quantitative pcr
essentially it's an absolute
quantification tool so really counts
individual dna rna molecules one by one
you don't need any standard curve you're
really looking at individual molecules
and detecting those
reliably it provides increased
sensitivity
so you can detect those nucleic acids
with
single molecule sensitivity
and you have high precision you can
measure the quantity with uh
only a few percent of uncertainty so
it's obviously
a great um technology and
again focusing on the differences
between rt
qpcr and digital pcr the workflow would
essentially be the same
if you think again about the workflow i
presented above
you would still with digital pcr start
from an extracted sample so you would
collect
transport extract and instead of analyze
the sample
using rtqpcr you analyze the sample
using another instrument
which is performing digital pcr similar
chemistry similar assays
so from a workflow standpoint very
comparable so it can be easily
implemented
in labs that are already doing real-time
qpcr
but real-time qpcr as i said is mostly
for detection
of dna rrna
whereas digital pcr brings to the table
increased sensitivity absolute
quantification and also and that's i
think is interesting in the current
context of kubern-19 detection and
diagnostics it has low variability
between samples between um users and
between labs
and it's robust again against inhibitors
so it can essentially be implemented
in very similar ways anywhere you would
perform the assay giving similar results
across the globe which is interesting
when you want to compare performance of
assays here and there but what has to be
said again is that
right now our tpcr is the workhorse
technology
and it's the kuben 19 diagnostic
standard
and digital pcr still remains
a research tool and is only today
transitioning to diagnostics
and mostly has a purimetery tool for
kubern19 in particular
the hope we have at stila is that by
using digital pcr
we could indeed have a valuable valuable
asset
uh in the battle against cuban 19
by increasing sensitivity and by
increasing sensitivity basically we
could diagnose
patients who come in either late early
or late
into the testing facilities
if you see this middle graph here at the
moment real time pcr
is only able to diagnose patients who
have
significant amounts of virus from the
samples collected
and this occurs you know at the peak of
of the infection
but we know that patients can already
transmit the disease early on
when they are asymptomatic and so it's
interesting to increase
the scope of diagnostics to the left of
this curve early on
disease and also what's happening
actually quite frequently
in in hospitals is that patients
unfortunately come in a bit late
already having severe symptoms but at a
point in the disease where it's not the
virus that's causing the symptoms
anymore it's the
immunoresponse of the patient that's
causing the symptoms
and in those cases again it's hard to
detect the virus from nasal swabs
using rt-pcr and so digital pcr could
also expand
the realm of diagnostics to the right of
this curve
and if we basically increase our ability
to diagnose patients we can really
understand better who's
has been infected by the disease and
who's not and then targets um
how we want to treat patients
accordingly
so how did pcr achieves higher
sensitivity higher precision
um it's by using a process
a workflow which uh amounts to
the following so you start off with your
your sample that you want to analyze
that contains
multiple amounts of dna
or rna molecules so various
amounts of dna molecules instead of
analyzing the sample
in bulk you start off by partitioning
the samples into
tens of thousands of subpartitions so
you cut
up your sample into micro volumes
and by doing so you isolate the dna
or rna molecules in different
compartments
so you initially have a complex sample
on the left
and then when you look at a single
partition it's a very simple
subsample where you only have one or two
dna molecules rna molecules
so you basically have simplified your
sample and then you're going to perform
pcr in all those partitions
but each pcr is going to be essentially
very keen because you're going to start
by your pcr reaction with a single
molecule and you don't have
cross reactions happening you don't have
noise in your pcr reactions and so you
get very clean
pcr amplifications and this pcr
amplification is then
combined with some some dyes that will
color
the droplets or the partitions that
contain the
dna or rna molecules of interest in some
color so blue in this case
so at the end of pcr you have a number
of partitions
which are colored and some who are not
colored
those who are colored become the
positive partitions those who are not
are the negatives
and then by just counting the number of
positives and negatives and applying
some statistics you can
go back and calculate very precisely the
amount of dna you had in your sample
uh so in this example you can get you
know only two or five percent precision
or uncertainty which is really
remarkable
but also think about the fact that if
you had a single partition becoming
positive this would mean that you had a
single
dna molecule in your sample and you
would really reliably detect this single
molecule
so you can have single molecule
sensitivity
so the workflow that i'll explain a bit
in more in detail is the
crystal crystal digital pcr workflow
that we have developed at stella
technologies
where we do this uh three-step workflow
partitioning pcr and analysis
in a format which we call droplet
crystals we partition the sample into
tens of thousands of
micro droplets and then those micro
droplets
self-assemble into a large 2d array that
we call a droplet crystal
and then we do the amplification step
and we do the readouts
using three fluorescence channels so we
do the readout using a blue
a green and red uh fluorescence
readout and this allows us to detect
three different
dna or rna targets and reliably quantify
those three different dna rna targets in
our sample
so this is our unique workflow to enable
multiplexing
precision and sensitivity in digital pcr
to perform the workflow we have
developed and we implement in the lab to
automate this workflow
we have our nike system so the nike
system
is built around a key consumable
our sapphire chip so this is a
microfluidic consumable
that really integrates and automates the
whole digital pcr workflow
and this is the key aspect in digital
pcr
how do you automate the partitioning
step the amplification step and the
readout
when you have to process tens of
thousands of partitions in parallel
so this automation is performed using
microfluidics and in our case using our
sapphire chip
so the sapphire chip is then processed
using two different instruments
nike geo than the prism 3 instrument
and at the end of the workflow also very
important
to enable our users and to enable
those who will be performing the test we
have our intuitive
crystal minor software that analyzes the
data
and gives results out to our users in
the numbers of
dna rna molecules present in their
sample
so our solution has three main
advantages when it comes to performing
high precision genetic analysis
it's easy to use as you'll see it's a
very simple process
and it's all integrated in a single
consumable
it's also a fast process it's the same
time to result as standard rt pcr
so about two hours and a half to get the
results out of the sapphire chips
and uh we also have this ability this
unique ability to detect
rna dna targets in three colors so you
can get more information out of our
out of your your samples
so as i said the heart of the product is
the sapphire chip so if you look at the
back side of the sapphire chip this is
where the automation takes place
it builds upon our proprietary
and patented partitioning technology
which allows us to take
the about you know 25 microliters of pcr
mix that is put in the chip and
transform that
into an array of 25 000 to 30 000
droplets
in each of the four chambers of the chip
so
each chip is capable of processing
fortune four samples in parallel
um and we can reliably make those uh
25 to 30 000 droppets uh in in our
samples using this microtic technology
and then process
the whole chip the whole samples in the
workflow in the chip
ease of use for us is key we have a
workflow which
can be performed by any lab technician
that is
accustomed to doing a pcr rt pcr
so to really prepare the chip you only
have to take the chip
remove the white caps uh and then
pipettes 25 micrometers of pcr mix
into the inlet ports the chemistries
that are being used are chemistries that
are
routinely found into in pcr labs so we
have a
specific master mix that needs to be
used that we provide
from quantum biosciences but then it's
compatible with
any type of probes tagman probes or even
evergreen intercalating dyes to perform
a variety of assays pcr assays that are
being done in labs that would adopt the
technology
so once you've loaded the chip you
transfer the chip into the geode
and the geode will inject the pcr mix
into the chip
and when it does the injection of the
pcr mix into the chip it
continuously breaks down the pcr mixing
those
droplet crystals of 30 000 droplets per
sample
and immediately after it performs the
pcr amplification
so the partitioning and amplification
tab steps take about two hours and
ten minutes and once this uh
step is performed the chips are strength
are
transferred to the second instruments to
the prism 3 instrument
which takes high-resolution images of
the droplet crystals
using three different fluorescence
channels so a blue channel
that can detect typically fan dyes a
green channel that can detect
uh big hex rocks size three dyes
so a broad range of the dyes can be used
for this channel and then a red
channel that can detect sci-fi or sci-fi
point
scythe 5.5 dies sorry
the readout is fast so it's less than a
minute per sample
um so basically in about two hours and
15 minutes you have the results
uh for your 12 samples that you would
have processed in the geode
and the last step that needs to be
automated is the image analysis and we
do so with our
crystal miner software which builds upon
ai tools to do image analysis and
extract the fluorescence
of all the droplets that you have in
your droplet crystals
so we process tens of thousands of
profits image droplets and we process
them through our
neural network software to make sure
that we can reliably detect those
droplets exclude artifacts measure the
fluorescence and basically
give out results which are one reliable
but also can be intuitively analyzed by
our users
to classify the droplets as positive for
the blue channel green channel
or red channel so it's really a powerful
software
which also provides you know quality
control trustworthy quality control
for example in terms of quality control
something that's quite unique
with the nike system is that you can
actually
look at the droplet crystals as the
images
of those droplet crystals and you can
overlay on top of the images
which droplets are positive for uh
one or the other of your your targets
and this is a reliable tool
for users who want to understand really
what's happening in their samples
and look at the quality of the results
that they're getting
so in summary with this
crystal digital pcr workflow and with
the nike system
we have enabled the automation of the
digital pcr workflow
in a single consumable uh with three
channel
fluorescence detection and that takes
the
in that takes place in about two hours
and 30 minutes with only about five
minutes of hands-on time
so really uh automated workflow that can
be simply implemented in the labs
and so this digital pcr workflow um
has already been implemented for a
variety of applications
um so the dominating applications i
would say prior to discover 19 epidemic
was oncology but you had applications
for environmental science for food
testing
for infectious disease any any
domain of science where you need to do
genetics molecular testing has
potential uses for digital pcr and
digital pcr is really becoming the new
standard
for precision genetic analysis
for those who are interested in learning
more about digital pcr
in itself i can point you to a website
called gene pi
which we have built together with some
collaborators
as really an educational portal for
people who want to learn how digital pcr
performs
learn about the math behind the
statistics and how it can be applied
to different cases like rare event
mutation detections
like copy number variation
quantification or
to perform more complex assays like
drop-off assays
so really good tool to learn more about
digital pcr in general
not just on the nike system but in
general how digital pcr can be useful
for genetics
so let me now turn to how digital pcr
again can be used
in the context of qubit 19 and
our battle against the epidemic so as i
said
something that we investigated
at stila is whether or not digital pcr
could be used to increase sensitivity
and reduce
false negative rates that have been
observed by real-time pcr
so to do so um the first thing that we
need
is an assay that can be used to detect
the sarso
virus and so we have developed
an assay to do exactly that with our
partners
apex bio who are based in suzhou in
china
so we have worked with ethics bio suju
very early on in the outbreak of the
epidemic we were
lucky in contact with our partners there
who were you know
first to witness the outbreak and so as
of
starting even in january this we started
working on the development of this assay
which is uh the currently the only
uh threeplex assay for the detection of
starscope 2. so the assay is set up as
following
so we have detection on the fan channel
of the orf-1ab gene of the source code 2
virus
on the green channel we detect the
nucleoprotein n
of the viral genome and in the
cy5 channel we have a human house group
keeping gene that's being detected as an
internal
endogenous control which is also very
important to make sure
that when you get a negative result it's
a true negative and not
a malfunction of the instrument of the
essay itself
so this assay is available to any user
uh
who wants to implement the nike system
in digital pcr
to source for source code to detection
and it's available worldwide
before i go into the presentation of
some of the results we've obtained with
this
essay i'll talk a bit about
the design of the assay itself and
how you can use the multiplexing
capability
of the the nike system to have increased
sensitivity
and so here what's shown is a picture
of the structure of the viral genome so
what's interesting with source code 2 is
you know it's a very long
genome for our virus it's almost 30 kb
long
and so we have chosen to
have two different targets in our assay
that are spread apart
one from another into genome so one of
our targets is
rf1abg so it's located to the left of
the genome
and the other is on the n gene so those
two targets are separated from one
another
with a distance of you know more than 10
000
bases base pairs so they are very spread
apart
and what's interesting here is that in
practice
viral rna once it's analyzed
in digital pcr or real-time pcr
the viral rna is quite highly fragmented
this fragmentation of the genome occurs
probably already at collection it most
likely occurs during transport where
the virus itself is sliced and then
it also occurs quite extensively in the
extraction process
so when you analyze the virus itself you
don't analyze 30 kb
fragments you only have fragments of a
few hundred kbs
and so one genome actually
becomes two different fragments at the
very least detected in our system
you get you if you have one genome in
your sample you would get one green
droplet and you would get
one red droplet so you get two events
per genome
and so basically uh by looking at the
two different channels
you basically double the probability of
detecting one genome
by looking at those two different
fragments and that's something that's
quite unique with digital pcr is because
you have this single molecule
detection capability on each channel
by looking at the two channels
simultaneously
on on the same assay you really
can increase sensitivity when you detect
a single droplets in either
of the channels it tells you that you
have
one genome and you reliably
detect one genome of the virus in your
sample
so that is uh something to keep in mind
when you design an assay in digital pcr
and you think about whether or not the
dna is fragmented or not you can
cleverly use
um the assay design to increase
sensitivity for example
and this is what we've done so
we've checked what the sensitivity or
assay was
by running some spiked experiments with
positive controls of
r1ab and nucleoprotein sequences
and one something that's expected in
digital pcr
you have very good linearity of your
dilutions
so you can really precisely quantify
your targets
across a broad range of viral
concentrations
and we have found that we have a limit
of detection
uh that is about 0.6 copies per
microliter
and 0.9 for each of the two genes and
again that those are concentrations
where you have 95
uh probability of detecting the virus
and that is lower than what has been
found
in a real-time pcr at least two-fold if
not five-fold lower than what is
custom with real-time pcr assays
and again there are approaches which
allows us also to combine those results
and increase the sensitivity by looking
at the results
together and not separately
i forgot to mention obviously
specificity is important as well
and we have observed the new false
positives
in negative samples and specificity is
also verified in this in this assay
so the first results i want to show on
patient samples
is a study that we performed in
collaborations with the hospital in
france
uh and
there this study was really targeted at
looking
at samples where the patient came in
the patient had a cd scan which showed
abnormalities so it had the patient had
pneumonia like symptoms they had ct
abnormalities
but then when they performed pcr on
nasal swabs after extraction
the the pcr results came out negative
and so the hospitals are really having
issues now with such samples and such
individuals because in the hospitals
they don't know
they should put such patients encode
positive
facilities or cover negative facilities
and yes today covered 19
is a major contribution to pneumonia's
pneumonia right now but it's not the
only reason why people have pneumonia
and you don't want to put someone that
has pneumonia but not
corbin 19 next to people who have
copenhagen that can only make things
worse
um so we wanted to check whether or not
the neca system could be helpful here
and so we use our naked system together
with the kubern 19 kids
and um and so the early data that we can
share
and that's data we only got as of last
week so this is very recent results
we took 10 of such patients that came in
the hospital
and we processed them in qpcr first they
were negative
and then we reprocessed them in digital
pcr and out of those 10 patients that
were negative in qpcr
four came out to be clearly positive in
digital pcr
so that's a significant improvement
in terms of diagnostics for the six
others
they are negative in digital pcr they
could still have very low amounts of
virus that was undetectable
but it's likely that those are actually
negative patients and it's probably more
makes more sense to treat those positive
digital pcr patients positives
include positive facilities in the
hospital
so it's a 40 increase in terms of
uh sensitivity on those specific qpcr
negative patients and that's a
significant result something here
showing how digital pcr can be used as a
complementary tool for uh diagnostics of
critical patients
as those
a similar study that can be uh
shared today is one that we performed at
the yashu marseille again it's a
hospital
in france and there
the goal of the study was to look at
qpcr results which are
basically dubious doubtful so when you
have a
qpcr results you typically use look at
the ct value that comes out so at which
cycle
do you get a fluorescence readout for
your sample and typically when the
patient when the sample has a lot of
virus the ct value is low you
find out fluorescence values early on in
the amplification step so the ct is
below 35
and uh but when you have low amount of
virus
you can have amplification at very late
stages when the ct is then above 35
but it's unclear if
when you have a city that's above 35
whether this is a true positive
results or if it's positive because of
of some polymers error or some
amplification that's not specific to the
source co2 virus
so we
we looked at uh at a set of samples
uh we looked at 15 samples that were
negative by qpcr
12 that were clearly positive with city
values below 35
and 18 with who had doubtful results
first interesting result is that amongst
the negative we had one recall
a sample that was clearly positive by
digital pcr
again it's likely to be due to the
increased sensitivity of digital pcr
compared
to real-time pcr
out of the 12 positive samples we could
see that we could reliably detect
the virus by a digital pcr and also we
found
a good correlation between the ct value
and the quantity of iris that's detected
by digital pcr the lower
the ct value the higher the
concentration measured by digital pcr
the correlation is not full because here
the qpcr
assay is not standardized
and so it's hard to really say and
compare qpcr results one to another
something that i pointed out to before
without any standard curve you can't
really compare patient a to patient b
which could have been processed
differently which could have different
contents of inhibitors etc
but at least there is a good correlation
as expected now looking at the 18
doubtful results in in qpcr
those had ct values that ranged
from 34 to about 40
in terms of ct values and we processed
them by digital pcr
and the key results is that we actually
reliably detected
the viral the virus in 11 out of those
18 samples
seven only out of 18 came out negative
and so here again we have more than half
of those
doubtful results which become clearly
positive
by digital pcr and we could then use
this confirmatory tool
in terms of patient management in
hospitals to make sure that patients who
have ict values
but for digital pcr positive can be put
in kubernetes
facilities and hospitals and those who
are negative on both
can be treated separately with less risk
of
infecting others so those are only two
studies
preliminary at this point in time
but who interestingly point out clearly
advantages of using digital pcr compared
to qpcr
what has to be said is that this
approach
is now routinely used in china um
in in the center for disease control
which are using a digital pcr to confirm
doubtful results
on several hundreds of samples and this
is something that we hope we can also
uh implement uh in in europe and in the
us
with with us with our approach
so this was an illustration of how
digital pcr can be used to cover 19
detection and quantification but digital
pcr as i said can be used for
a number of other challenges
in the realm of genetic analysis and
molecular diagnostics
so we have a number of application notes
that can be found on our website
and those results and this approach can
also be uh
found in the publication we have on our
website
specifically dedicated to kubern 19
detection
[Music]
so with this i conclude my presentation
so i really want to thank the
the doctors and physicians who have
helped us
analyze samples patient samples and
institute
and at the yes marseille so
professor mikhail ronkou and dr amar
bhum
so a big thank you to them and again
thank you also
to the organizers of the conferences for
giving us the opportunity to present
those results on how digital pcr can be
a helpful tool
in the fight against covet 19. thanks
for your attention